ich befasse mich viel mit den USA und
bin der Meinung dass die USA ein ganz
wichtiger Partner für uns sind
wirtschaftlich wie auch politisch sie
sind ein wichtiger investitionspartner
unsere Unternehmen produzieren in den
USA amerikanische Unternehmen
produzieren hier aber sie sind eben
nicht nur ein interessenspartner sondern
ein wertepartner und wir leben ja in
einer Zeit in der das geopolitische
Umfeld immer schwieriger wird wir haben
China und Russland und viele Autokratien
auf der einen Seite wir haben
Demokratien auf der anderen Seite wir
haben natürlich auch viele Länder in der
Mitte die unentschlossen sind auf welche
Seite sie tatsächlich gehen wollen und
es stehen letztendlich unterschiedliche
ordnungs- und Werte Modelle sich
gegenüber und in einer solchen Situation
sollten wir zusammenhalten das heißt
allerdings nicht für mich dass wir nicht
auch sehen müssen vor welchen großen
Herausforderungen die USA tatsächlich
auch stehen ein unglaublich gespaltenes
Land politisch gesellschaftlich sozial
für riesengroßen Demokratie
Herausforderungen und wir haben jetzt
gerade die mithören elections in den USA
gehabt die Republikaner haben ordentlich
aufgeholt fürs Haus davor für sensitive
also Repräsentantenhaus eine rote Welle
hat nicht stattgefunden aber
nichtsdestotrotz haben beiden wird
unglaublich unter Druck sein die
nächsten zwei Jahre weil er nämlich
nicht mehr aus einer Hand regieren kann
sondern die Demokraten haben definitiv
oder werden wahrscheinlich eine Kammer
verloren haben wenn ich sogar beide und
dementsprechend wird der stärker unter
Druck stehen und unabhängig davon bin
ich der Meinung dass Europa sehr gut
daran tut die EU sehr gut daran tut wenn
wir mehr auch in eigene
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und eigene
Verteidigungsfähigkeit investieren dazu
gehört zum Beispiel auch dass
Deutschland das 2% Ziele erfüllt der
NATO dass wir verteidigungsfähig auch
werden aber es bedeutet eben nicht für
mich dass wir uns von den USA abkoppeln
die USA sind ein ganz wichtiger Partner
also also selbst die Armeen aufbauen
aber Partner der USA bleiben kurze auf
der einen Seite unsere eigenen
Interessen verfolgen ganz klar
investieren und unsere eigene
wirtschaftliche Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
aber auch Verteidigungsfähigkeit und auf
der anderen und natürlich auch die
Probleme sehen die wir in den USA haben
und auf der anderen Seite trotzdem
versuchen so weit wie möglich mit den
Amerikanern kooperieren und die Zeit
auch mit der beiden Administrationen
jetzt noch nutzen denn wir weiß was 2024
bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen passiert
nutzen um die wirtschaftliche
Integration mit den USA voranzutreiben
was hat beiden denn bislang eigentlich
so geleistet das ist oder ist oder hat
er geleistet dass er nicht mehr Donald
Trump ist das war meine Frage die frage
ich mich schon seit längerem ja
irgendwie kam dabei mir nicht so viel
rüber also die vier Jahre unter Trump
war ja für die Europäer und für die
Deutschen wirklich ausgesprochen
schwierig nicht nur wegen des
amerikanischen da würde ich tatsächlich
sagen Handelskrieg mit China und
steigenden Zellen darunter hat auch die
deutsche Industrie ordentlich gelitten
sondern auch weil Trump ja Zölle auf
Aluminium und Stahl aus Europa auch aus
Deutschland am verhängt hat und immer
wieder auch mit autozüllen gedroht hat
und dadurch auch die ganze
Weltwirtschaft ganz schön durcheinander
gebracht hat also es waren wirklich
schwierige vier Jahre und mit der beiden
administrat Administration würde ich
sagen ist zum einen ein Transatlantiker
zurückgekommen der tatsächlich einen
Wert in den transatlantischen
Beziehungen auch sieht der anders mit
uns umgeht und der Ton macht eben auch
die Musik das Vertrauen ist es wieder
gestiegen und wir haben gemeinsam ein
Initiative also Europa die EU und die
USA ein transatlantischen Handels und
Technologie Rat auf den Weg gebracht wo
eben viele der Konflikte auch angegangen
werden ob nun bei
luftfahrtssubventionen oder eben bei
Zöllen und da sind wir schon auch einen
Schritt vorangekommen aber es stimmt
natürlich auch die Amerikaner verfolgen
ganz knallhart ihre Interessen im
letzten großen Gesetz was sie ja auch
erwähnt hatten im sogenannten in flation
reduction Act steckt eine Menge drin was
America first ist in der Handelspolitik
und darunter leiden natürlich auch
deutsche Unternehmen
mehrere große Gesetze
Gesetzesinitiativen auf dem Weg gebracht
man merkt ihr es war in Amerika Plädoyer
also ich bin kein Amerikaner und
natürlich mag man innenpolitisch die
Situation anders beurteilen ich finde
wir müssen Sie von unserer Warte aus
beurteilen und was die
Außenwirtschaftspolitik und Außenpolitik
angeht muss ich sagen hat sich unter
beiden nichts wesentlich verbessert also
der der Handelskrieg gegen China ist
eskaliert also mit den neuen Gesetzen
mit den neuen Sanktionen was ja uns
indirekt betrifft weil die USA ja immer
also mal das ist ja auch etwas was sich
kein anderes Land dieser Welt
herausnimmt die USA machen ja nicht nur
Sanktionen die sie dann ihre Unternehmen
vorschreiben sondern sie schreiben sie
für den Rest der Welt auch vor das heißt
auch für europäische Unternehmen in der
amerikanische Komponenten verbaut in
bestimmten Bereichen ist jetzt auch von
den Sanktionen betroffen darf also nicht
mehr China beliefern das ist ein echtes
Problem und wie gesagt diese
subventionspakete das übersteigt ja das
was Trump gemacht hat also das wirklich
jetzt ganz konkret Unternehmen gefördert
werden die in den USA produzieren und
ausländische Exporteure entsprechend
benachteiligt werden das ist eigentlich
klassisch ja Protektionismus oder wie
man das immer nennen will also mit
Freihandel hat das jedenfalls wirklich
gar nichts mehr zu tun und ich finde wir
müssen eben ich habe nichts gegen
Partnerschaft im Gegenteil die USA ist
auch ein richtiger ein wichtiger Markt
für uns also natürlich sollten wir
wirtschaftlich kooperieren aber wir
müssen unsere eigenen Interessen sehen
und ich finde europa muss wirklich
aufpassen dass wir gerade bei der
kritischen Infrastruktur nicht nur von
China unabhängig sind das sollten wir
auch sein also das weiße große Debatte
Hafen und Huawei und Bauteile da ist
völlig richtig sollten wir aufpassen
dass wir nicht abhängig werden aber noch
viel abhängiger in der ganz elementaren
kritischen Infrastruktur nämlich in der
Finanzwirtschaft und in der
digitalwirtschaft sind wir von den USA
und wir haben das damals gemerkt da ging
es um die Iran Sanktionen die Europa
nicht mitmachen wollte weil Iran ja das
Atomprogramm eingestellt hatte und
Europa war nicht in der Lage sich quasi
aus diesem
sanktionskrieg rauszuhalten weil die USA
die Macht hatten über ihre
Finanzwirtschaft quasi uns das
aufzuzwingen und die digitalwirtschaft
ist noch wichtiger also in jedem Auto
alles ist ist in Zukunft Software und
wenn das amerikanische Anbieter sind
dann sind wir irgendwann nur noch die
werkzusammenschrauber dann geht auch die
die Wertschöpfung weg also deswegen
wünsche ich mir eine europäische Politik
die und auch eine deutsche Politik die
wirklich diese elementaren Interessen
sieht und wenn ich dann immer höre wie
quasi die Geschlossenheit des westlichen
Bündnis geboren wird also wenn ich das
die chiffriere heißt das wir sollen uns
unterordnen und unterwirflich sein weil
das ist der Preis der Geschlossenheit
ansonsten müssen wir eben unsere eigenen
Interessen vertreten das heißt aber dann
auch mal dass es Streit gibt das ist
doch klar und wir müssen und ich die
französische Politik ist da viel
offensiver also dort wurde diese dieser
Inflation reduction ganz anders
kritisiert als bei uns bei uns spielte
das kaum eine Rolle und ich finde das
ist ein echtes Problem letzter Punkt
Verteidigungsausgaben also da muss ich
ehrlich sagen natürlich bin ich der
Meinung dass die Bundeswehr in der Lage
sein muss Deutschland zu verteidigen
dafür ist sie da aber ich frage mich
wieso der doch erhebliche aufwuchs im
Militäretat in den letzten Jahren nicht
dazu geführt hat dass man dazu besser in
der Lage ist sondern das offenbar das
waren ja immer die Meldungen die
Soldaten noch nicht mal irgendwie
wechselunterwäsche und Strümpfe haben
also insoweit muss ich ehrlich sagen ich
glaube es liegt nicht an der Menge an
Geld die wir in Militär investieren
sondern eher in der Art und Weise wie
dieses Geld verwendet wurde und wofür es
geschmissen wurde also wir haben
wirklich gesellschaftlich wichtigere
Aufgaben als uns hochzurüsten wir haben
ein malar des Bildungssystem wir haben
eine bröckelnde Infrastruktur also es
gibt wirklich viele Dinge die wir tun
sollten und wofür wir dringend Geld
brauchen weil da geht es auch um die
Zukunft als Wirtschaftsstandort
andere Länder da sehen sie bröckeln die
Infrastrukturen und es geht bei der
Bundeswehr erstmal um Ausrüstung und wir
sind wir sind meilenweit von zwei
Prozent Ziel entfernt und dann die
Aufwüchse da gibt es dann auch Inflation
und Personalkosten steigen und viele
andere Dinge mehr was wir einfach in
Deutschland an der Stelle haben und
Beschaffungsbereich ich glaube da weiß
ich worüber ich rede wir sind viel zu
bürokratisch da hängen viel zu viele
Juristen drin und wenn sie mit
Frankreich ist das kein Vergleich der
französische Präsident bestimmt über die
Außenpolitik er bestimmt im
Verteidigungspolitik das wissen sie
genauso gut wie ich wir sind eine
repräsentative Demokratie und das ist
ein bisschen schwieriger bestimmte Dinge
an der durch und umzusetzen wir nochmal
auf Europa zurückkommen es mangelt
Europa nicht an Geld
in dieser Förderperiode stehen Europa
mit und Next Generation von 1,8
Billionen Euro
nach Europa schieben sollten
wir schon richtig zuhören ich sage nur
aktuell stehen im europäischen Raum bei
den Fonds und beim nächstgeneration
Fonds rund 1,8 Billionen Euro zur
Verfügung weil beim beim Netz Generation
Fonds die Hälfte von 740 Milliarden sind
Darlehen das muss ich mal umsetzen in
Europa da muss auch Brüssel sich